dominique from dominique's pizza bakes
the same amount of pizza every day she
used to spend eight dollars each day on
using the oven and a dollar fifty on
ingredients for each pizza so eight
dollars each day on using the oven and a
dollar fifty on ingredients for each
pizza one day the price for the
ingredients increased from a dollar
fifty to two dollars per pizza
dominique made some calculations and
found that she should make eight pizzas
more each day so the expenses for a
single pizza would remain the same and
assume they're saying the total expenses
for a single pizza because clearly the
ingredients the ingredients cost is not
the same we're talking about the total
ingredients so if we were to spread the
cost of the oven across all of the
pizzas
write an equation to find how or the
total cost for the oven per day to
spread that across all the pizzas
write an equation to find out how many
pizzas dominique baked each day before
the change in price use p to represent
the number of pizzas
so let's just think about her total cost
per pizza before and then her total cost
per pizza after if she bakes eight more
pizzas
so before we're going to use p to say
this is that's the number of pizzas she
baked per day before the change in price
so before the change in price on on a
given day she would spend eight dollars
on the oven
and then a dollar fifty on ingredients
for each pizza so 1.5 or a dollar fifty
times the number of pizzas this would be
her total cost on all the pizzas in that
day it's the oven cost plus it's the
ingredients cost so if you wanted this
on a per pizza basis
you would just divide by the number of
pizzas
now let's think about what happens after
the change in price after the change in
price her cost per day for the oven is
still eight dollars
but now she has to spend two dollars per
pizza on ingredients so two dollars per
pizza and instead of saying that she's
making pea pizzas let's say that she's
now baking eight more pizzas each day so
it's going to be p
plus
p plus eight and so this is going to be
her total cost for all of the pizzas
she's now baking
and so if you want it on a per pizza
basis you well she's now making p plus
eight pizzas you would divide by p plus
eight
and the problem tells us that these two
things are equivalent here you had a
higher cost ingredients per pizzas but
since you're in since you are now baking
more pizzas you're spreading the oven
cost among amongst more and more pizzas
so let's think about what p has to be
p is has to be some number some number
of pizzas so that these two expressions
are equal her total cost per pizza
before which he only made p is going to
be the same as her total cost per pizza
when she's making p plus eight pizzas so
these two things need to be equal so we
did that first part or we did what they
asked us we wrote an equation to find
out how many pizzas dominique baked each
day before the change in price and we
used p to represent the number of pizzas
but now for fun let's actually just
solve for p
so let's just simplify things a little
bit and actually so this part right over
here actually let's just cross multiply
this on both sides or another way of
thinking is multiply both sides times p
plus 8 and multiply both sides times p
so if we multiply by p plus 8 and we
multiply by p
we multiply by p plus 8 and we multiply
by p
that cancels with that
that cancels with that on the left hand
side so let's see we have to just do the
distributive property twice right over
here what is p times 8 plus 1.5 p well
that's going to be 8 p i'm just
multiplying the p times this stuff first
plus
1.5 p squared and now let's multiply now
let's multiply the 8 times both of these
terms
so plus
plus 8 times 1.5 that is 12 plus
12 p and that's going to be equal to
let's see let's multiply p times all of
this business so that's going to be
equal to 8
p 8 times p is 8 p
and let's see i could distribute these
terms and then multiply by p
so 2 times p is 2p
times p is 2p squared plus 2p squared
and then 2 times 8 is 16
times p is 16 p
so now we have well we essentially end
up with a quadratic equation but let's
simplify it a little bit so that we can
either factor it or apply the quadratic
formula
so let's see let's let's throw
let's
subtract 2p squared from actually let's
subtract 1.5 p squared from both sides
so subtract 1.5
p squared subtract 1.5
p squared
actually let me just put everything on
the left hand side just because that's
might be a little bit more intuitive so
let's subtract 2p
squared from both sides subtract 2p
squared from both sides let's subtract
let's subtract 16p from both sides so we
have an 8p and a 12p and then we're
going to subtract the 16 p from both
sides and then oh actually let's
subtract
an 8 p as well from both sides we have a
16 p and an 8 p so that actually works
out quite well so now we've subtracted
8 p from both sides 16 p from both sides
we've essentially subtracted all of this
stuff from both sides
and we are left with
let's see 1.5 i'll start i'll do it in
degree order 1.5 p squared minus 2p
squared is negative
negative
0.5
p squared
and let's see these
cancel out 12p minus 16p is minus 4p
and then we have plus 64
plus 64. and then that is going to be
equal to zero
that is going to be equal to zero
and just to simplify this a little bit
or just make this a little bit cleaner
let's multiply both sides of this
equation
by
negative 2
by negative 2. i want the coefficient
over here to be 1. so then we get p
squared plus 8
p
p squared
plus eight p
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to let's see
negative oh negative times negative two
so minus 128
is going to be equal to
0.
so let's see if we can factor this can
we think of two numbers where if we take
the product we get negative 128
and if we were to
and if we were to add them together we
get positive eight so they're gonna have
different signs right over here so let's
see if we say 12 times
let's see 12 times well let's see what
could we what numbers could this be
so if we were to think about 128 is the
same thing as
this is 16
let's see 16 goes into 128. let me work
through this 16 goes into one
28.
does it go eight times
eight times six
is
eight times six is forty-eight
eight times ten is eighty plus forty is
128 yep goes eight times so sixteen and
8 seem to work so if you have positive
16 and negative 8 they would mu their
product would be negative 128. so we can
factor this out as
p plus 16
times p
minus eight is equal to zero
now this is going to be equal to zero if
one of these two at least one of these
is going to be equal to zero so
we have two solutions either p plus 16
is going to be equal to zero or p minus
8 is equal to 0.
this one right over here subtract 16
from both sides you get p is equal to
negative 16. here you get p is equal to
8 if you add 8 to both sides
now we're talking about a number of
pizzas made so we're not this one
doesn't apply this would be like her
dominique eating 16 pizzas or somehow
destroying 16 pizzas a day we're not
interested in that solution so if we
want the solution to the original
question the number of pizzas she made
before the increase in price she made
eight pizzas she made
eight pizzas per day so p right over
here needs to be equal to eight so
before the change in price she made
eight pizzas a day after the change in
price she made 8 more pizzas a day or 16
pizzas per day